alphaville ist luca meine lieben freunde
ich reagiere ja regelmäßig auf die
netflix serie to how to handle bei der
es darum geht dass fünf mädels und fünf
jungs auf einer einsamen insel sind und
sie dürfen nichts mehr haben wenn dem
doch der fall sein sollte geht etwas von
ihrem hunderttausend dollar preisgeld
runter über diese serie hinweg nähern
sich die teilnehmer harry und francesca
immer mehr an und am ende der serie
kommen die beiden dann sogar
schlussendlich zusammen
nun hat allerdings vor einer woche von
ceska dieses video hochgeladen und in
diesem video hat sie gesagt dass sie und
harry kein paar mehr sind zudem hat sich
ja noch grunde genommen und das ganze
ein bisschen erklärt ich habe darauf vor
einigen tagen bereits reagiert habe
allerdings gesagt ich warte noch mit
meiner meinung dazu
bis harry seiner ansicht hochgeladen hat
und das ist nun passiert die tage von
daher würde ich sagen schauen uns das
jetzt mal an typische anfang von unserem
video
ich hätte gedacht dass ich so etwas tun
muss aber das ist jetzt anscheinend an
dem punkt angelangt wo das jetzt echt
gar nicht gedacht ich mache euch mal
ganz kurz die unter drittel an weil ich
aber weiß das ja alle kein englisch
konnten
okay er sagt hier quasi einfach junge
leute ich hatte noch nie so etwas krass
wie die beziehungen von chefs beim mega
krasses habt ihr auch in der schau
gesehen als er sagt ihr zu beginn
erstmal das war wundervoll die ganze
zeit war toll und jetzt wird er
wahrscheinlich darauf eingehen warum sie
nicht mehr zusammen dass das jetzt
wieder unterbrechen aber das finde ich
da ist der beste ansatz um halt
irgendwie eine beziehung aufzubauen und
es war einfach nichts überstürzen
sondern halt wirklich einfach sagen hey
komm wir gucken erst mal wir sind
freunde wir schauen dass über längeren
zeitraum passt und dann kann man sich da
immer noch das ganze vertiefen
weil es finde ich ein besserer weg als
wenn man sagt wir sind direkt in der
beziehung oder märkte langfristigen
zeitraum nächst hab doch nicht so
richtig wissen wie ich meinen also da
bin ich auf jeden fall auf seiner seite
public opinion doch wenigstens dein
handy aus wenn du so laufen dass diese
kaka auf noten 360 p hochgeladen wurde
ok also hier sagt er jetzt jahres kamen
so viele kommentare nach francescas
video so alle haben ihre seite jetzt
sich angehört ihre meinung im cetera pp
ich hoffe dass sie auch meine meinung
auch anhört und auch meine sicht auf die
dinge respektiert und ja wie ich ja auch
schon in meiner reaktion auf das video
gesagt habe finde ich gut also dass er
dazu was gesagt hat ist auch richtig ist
auch wichtig ist auch notwendig und
bevor ich mir dann urteil bilde habe ich
mir auch erst mal seine seite an
[Musik]
okay das ist krass und das stimmt auch
das habe ich ja auch immer der letzte
weg schon oft orte händel vor zwei tagen
gezeigt beziehungsweise gesagt haben
francesca sich halt irgendwie an mehrere
leute angeschmissen
die hat mit bryce geliebäugelt als der
neue kam sie war mit kerzen whirlpool
und harry war wirklich die ganze zeit
nur von chaska fixiert also ich bin
jetzt folge 5 oder so glaube ich von 8
also mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen aber
das stimmt schon
francesca war ein bisschen player mäßig
unterwegs und harry hatte man noch augen
für sie das ist schon richtig in takt
vor
in den projektor deutschland primat kann
ich jetzt mit meiner frau denke also
erstmal diese untertitel denken oft dass
wir dann von ceska sagt meint er
irgendwie französisch oder irgendwie so
und ihr könnt den unterschied auch nicht
richtig vertrauen weil sie sind
automatisch übersetzt worden aber ich
glaube ich habe mitte hin so ein
bisschen das was erhält sagen will und
was er jetzt gesagt hat ist es war mega
krass für ihn dass er in der show und
francesca waren alles was obama aber die
schau war vorbei und alle flogen wieder
in ihre heimatorte zurück und die band
quasi alle auseinander
das war für ihn kraft dass das skyline
zum bordstein wieder zurück erst
daraufhin nach vancouver geflogen wo
anscheinend francesca lebt das wusste
ich gar nicht
und er hatte dort eine ganz andere von
jessy kennen gelernt der show und da
geht es jetzt weiter
ihr habt so viel gepostet auf social
media ihr habt basically alle eure
abonnenten nur gemacht weil die
zuschauer eure beziehung so nice fanden
und ihr habt ihr krank ausgespielt in
der öffentlichkeit das ist nichts
verbotenes klar natürlich wenn man mit
einer person zusammen ist ja auch social
media machten ihr seid beide in der
öffentlichkeit blabla dann ist natürlich
völlig okay das eda die ganze zeit euch
gegenseitig filmt oder so ich weiß dass
herr auf seinem profil auf videos mit 8
stelligen aufrufen hat mit francesca
aber jetzt zu sagen hey unsere beziehung
war total privat und so weiter und so
fort das stimmt ja irgendwie nicht oder
meinte er die zeit davor
wir schauen wir weiter
also er sagt mir ganz klar ja das erste
mal nachdem nämlich besucht hatte habe
ich dann direkt mit ihr schluss gemacht
sie hat mich besucht in australien das
von vancouver rübergeflogen also weiter
katze wirklich nicht auseinander leben
vancouver in kanada handel und realien
dieses long long distance relationship
allerdings sagt jetzt auch das nicht
kleinlich werden will er wird jetzt
nicht irgendwie andere leute mit in die
scheiße ziehen oder sie schlecht
dastehen lassen
ich freue mich dann warum das wieder 27
minuten geht dann sagt auch einfach den
grund
gustav software soll seine versprechen
was er gerade gesagt hat war dass der
haupt trennungsgrund also wirklich der
grund nummer eins warum er sich ja von
francesca getrennt hat einfach der grund
war dass er in einer dunklen zeit gerade
war da kann ich dir die lampe empfehlen
ich kann es nicht beurteilen ich weiß
nicht was weiter faser dabei ich habe
ihn noch nie getroffen wie noch nie mit
ihm unterhalten aber es hört sich damals
war das jetzt eine ausrede
von wegen ich habe einfach keinen bock
mehr aber das ist der grund ist bei mir
geht es gerade irgendwie ich so gut so
pro hasst ihren antrag gemacht
er verstehe ich nicht so richtig danach
soll
vom fenster
also die haben sich schon mal getrennt
checke ich jetzt wohl gerade sind dann
wieder zusammengekommen
und die jetzt ist gerade quasi das
zweite break up da ist ja noch viel mehr
zu der story als ich dachte
eine dämonin geber einer demo level 1
okay das halt auch so typisch in solchen
videos also ich meine ich selbst hat
auch schon zwei drei aktionen wo ich
ziemlich ernste videos machen musste
beispielsweise bei der pizza sache oder
bei der klub sache und ich habe mich
halt immer vorher extrem lange darauf
vorbereitet mit notizen und keine ahnung
was ich sagen wollte viele haben dann
auch geschrieben hey wirkt ein bisschen
irgendwie zu seriös keine ahnung was
aber ich finde es ist immer besser sich
sowas anzuschauen einfach so die fakten
zu bekommen
ich bin sehr fakten da sind der mensch
ich kann auch sehr emotional sein aber
ich finde gerade bei solchen videos
bringt es kein weiter wenn er das vor
der kamera sitzung macht
wo rede doch das ist seine visionen wie
gerade zehn sekunden reizen schreibt wir
einfach atmen auf den boden gut
ja classic auch stark dass sie nun
wieder stetig liebe französischen achse
übersetzer und beugt höre ich rechnete
das hoch an dass du dieses video direkt
von deinem herzen aus aufnimmt so wie du
gerade schon gesagt hast also long story
short rugby aber trotzdem hätte ich da
ein bisschen darauf vorbereiten können
finde ich eine schießhalle ähnlich
vor allem reality show inas said today
at hast du die kompetitive die ruinen
der halterin chips an die schulter
blicken
folglich hat der rat schon wieder
irgendwie ja ich bekomme also ich denke
dieses video bisher vorne und hinten
nicht aber so wie ich es bisher
verstanden aber sind schon bei über der
hälfte angekommen haben die diese
netzwerke aufgenommen gegen wie vor weil
sie nicht halt jahren sagen wir jetzt
mal dann sind sie nach dieser show ein
paar gewesen habe das allerdings
komplett privat gehalten dann kam die
show online sie haben gesagt hey wir
sind auch außerhalb der show zusammen
dann kam plötzlich der ganze öffentliche
druck durch die show und die ganze
aufmerksamkeit und jetzt können wir das
nicht mehr handeln und sind jetzt
auseinander
ich will den beiden wirklich nicht zu
nahe treten aber für mich sieht das
ganze danach aus von wegen
wir haben die schau gedreht und dann war
die show vorbei und alles cool es ist
die show raus und alle wollen dass wir
zusammen sind haven schuldigkeit
zusammen folgt und wir machen kappel
kooperation und haben ja alles mögliche
gemacht haben die freundschaft ja
ausgedribbelt bis zum gehtnichtmehr was
social media angeht und jetzt mache
beides ein video für sie völlig
aufgelöst sind oder sache nochmal zwei
die ich nun schon überlegt hatte gerade
war die beziehung waren die ganze zeit
zusammen zwar privat allerdings hat er
harry man noch seine sidekicks in
australien soll hatte francesca
irgendwas gesagt dass sie davon wind
bekommen hat dass er wohl nicht ganz
treu war und in dem moment wo die
beziehungen öffentlich ging war es für
harry halt so ok ich kann mir das nicht
mehr glauben
deswegen war jetzt schluss
das sind meine zwei ansichten wie seht
ihr das dies schreibt sie in die
kommentare
er hatte immer
sein standort hier zur verfügung
gestellten pro was ist das für eine
beziehung dass ihr euch nicht mehr dein
gehen vertraut schlag wieder eine halbe
halbzeit denn ich denke sie ist eine der
wunderbarsten menschen die leise
gesprochen werden
trotzdem bessere versetzungen als andere
nehmen abi gemacht hat
[Musik]
ich verstehe dich seine intention
er sagte gerade das von ceska der beste
mensch der welt ist er liebt sie man
noch über alles und er hatte mit ihr die
glücklichsten momente in seinem ganzen
leben brauche habe seid ihr da nicht
zusammen was ist dann der grundig text
ich im moment hier wirklich einfach nur
dass er noch nie so glücklich war in
seinem ganzen leben aber während der
streit phasen von ihm und francesca auch
noch nie so traurig
und er sagt andauernd da könnt ihr alle
meine freunde fragen und so weiter und
so fort ja okay ich frag mal kurz einen
holiday autos abheben
also er sagte jetzt auch noch mal hey
ihr habt das er in der show gesehen wo
halt aber alles fake war
ihr könnt alle meine freunde fragen ich
war wirklich so wir kennen deine freunde
nicht und er sagt jetzt auch noch mario
bitte pickt jetzt keine zeit also sagt
jetzt nicht ich bin noch von jasper
seite oder ich bin team harry oder keine
ahnung was sondern das reifste wer
einfach jetzt uns beide darüber in ruhe
zu lassen also es hört sich so an als ob
er wirklich fit gebaut hat und das jetzt
unter den teppich kehren will mit den
mit seiner argumentation von wegen sie
konnte immer sehen wo ich war sie konnte
mich immer anrufen alle meine freunde
wissen dass ich war echt fertig in der
beziehung und ihr habt ihr auf der schau
gesehen
für eine karte mit anderen da ein
bisschen ich nicht ich finde das ist
sehr viel und sehr viel mehr schein als
sein in diesem video
[Musik]
also ich habe bereits gesagt hatte
händel noch nicht zu ende geguckt ich
bin irgendwie folge 5 oder so morgen
kommt neuer teile auf meinem kanal
online.de nicht verpassen wollt dann
abonniert gern mal einen kanal in
unserem video klickt auf die glocke aber
dass ich so ganz checke ich es ja auch
meine kommentare und haben wir viele
geschrieben
harry hat ihren antrag gemacht warum
machst du ihren antrag wenn du jetzt
sagst ich musste mich einfach von ihr
trennen weil ich wusste dass sie es
ernst meint und dass ich mich nicht
längerfristig mit ihr sehr warum machst
du dann antrag
es hört sich so krass danach an als wenn
harry diese beziehung einfach dribbeln
wollte für social media reichweite und
francesca richtig emotional mit drin war
und jetzt sucht der halt gründe höre ich
war vorher wirklich eher auf deiner
seite weil ich von chats story nicht so
richtig verstanden habe und wenn du
jetzt angekommen werden mit guten fakten
und dem seriösen kurzen video sondern
welche auf deiner seite gehen sondern
das hört sich wirklich einfach nur das
hört sich nach ganz viel großer klappe
und nichts dahinter an
[Musik]
also bei diabetikern zeigt welche
doch gar nicht was ich sonst noch so
sagen darf oder nicht sagen darf so als
wenn ihr eure trennung da ihnen die mit
einem anwalt und mit der polizei
abgesprochen war was du sagen darf und
was nicht mit sie doch einfach stellung
zu den sagt und was francesca di
vorgeworfen hat von wegen irgendwie
fremd grubers und irgendwie nachrichten
die sie zugeschickt bekommen hat von ihm
mit anderen mädels hat sagte er gar nix
zu ist schick ich nicht dieses video ist
einfach unnötig
ich muss mir das nicht mehr weiter
anschauen
er kratzt einfach nur der oberfläche
sagt die ganze zeit ja ich habe auch
sachen gehört wo ich jetzt nicht so ganz
wusste okay was soll man zu anfang die
will man in einer beziehung nicht sehen
und leute man trennt sich ja nie
grundlos von einer person ja büro auf
der einen seite sagst du von chelseas
superstar sie ist der anderen liga für
dich sie ist der beste menschen
kennengelernt da sollte sie heißt es in
einem ganzen leben mit den chefs der
wundervollste mensch auf der welt aber
der anderen seite sagt du ich könnte mir
nichts ernstes mit ihr vorstellen
dieses video macht vorne und hinten
keinen sinn ich wollte allerdings
dennoch darauf reagieren und ich habe
mir wirklich viel von diesem video jetzt
erhofft das ist eine upload deswegen ist
er auch nur in einer geringen qualität
hier zur verfügung allerdings glaube ich
dass die hat der ton und die aussagen
wichtiger waren als jetzt das video an
sich allerdings will ich an der stelle
mein heutiges videos auch beenden wenn
die lieben freunde wie bereits in meiner
reaktion auf francescas braker video
gesagt wollte ich mir auf jeden fall
bevor ich meine eigene meinung bilden
auch noch harry seite dazu anschauen das
habe ich jetzt heute gemacht ich bin wie
bereits gesagt hundertprozentig team
francesca bietet ihr das ganze schreibt
sie gerne in die kommentare und wenn ihr
meinen morgigen teil von kurt enderli
verpassen wollt dann klickt hier oben
auf den smiley drauf denn dadurch werdet
ihr automatisch abonnent von meinem
kanal ist kostenlos und ihr verpasst
keine videos mehr und wenn ihr euch
nochmal von stars sicht auf diese ganzen
dinge anhören wollt dann klickt es hier
an
das ist nämlich meine reaktion auf von
jazz cars break up video es ist anders
als harry video ich bin offen
[Musik]